12 la sécurité à qui l'organisation
arabe des droits de l'homme demandent la
libération immédiate de tous les détenus
politiques
le changement espéré par la population
et notamment par la jeunesse avec
l'arrivée au pouvoir de bachar el-assad
se fait toujours attendre beaucoup de
jeunes privés de parole et de liberté
choisissent désormais l'exil d'autres
ont décidé de se battre de l'intérieur
le reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux à
damas caroline since et salah grammy
le groupe sait rien poule nasa watch
chante les villes choisies par de
nombreux jeunes à la recherche d'une
autre vie loin de leur pays
il raconte le quotidien d'une génération
qui ne peut s'exprimer librement
moi il n'y a pas une seule nuit où je ne
pense pas la situation politique
actuelle
ça me perturbe terriblement la politique
ça nous passionne tous notre plus grand
rêve c'est la paix si j'étais dans un
pays où jamais le droit de manifester je
le ferai pour exiger des changements en
syrie
cette musique orientale et ses paroles
qui contourne les interdits font le
succès de ce groupe mais s'agit d'une
jeunesse qui étouffe
on a demandé hier des règles sociales
qu'on doit respecter parce que nous
sommes ici au nord dans ce cadre là je
suis ni de la politique il y as se
refuse d'en parler comme la majorité des
syriens
ce célibataire de 26 ans travaille dans
le tourisme avec un objectif réussir
même s'il adore son pays elias
aimeraient voyager vivre autrement tu
parler librement les syriens en rêvent
mais peu osent le dire si la démocratie
c'est la liberté pour moi oui on a
besoin avancent razan elle ose dire
qu'il n'ya pas de démocratie en syrie
cette avocate de 29 ans dénonce le
pouvoir vacille qui emprisonne et
harcèlent tous les opposants
l'état n'a aucune considération pour
nous pour lui on n'est pas des citoyens
même pas des êtres humains on est moins
bien traités que des cafards son combat
là totalement isolé sa famille la
réprouve
ses amis ont fui trop de danger de
pression je me suis préparé
psychologiquement être arrêter à
n'importe quel moment je n'ai pas peur
ces deux dernières années j'ai été
constamment convoqué par les services de
sécurité ces derniers mois il
venus interroger mes proches mes voisins
internet et son unique espace de liberté
la police lui interdit de quitter le
territoire
razan ira jusqu'au bout de son combat
pour le respect des droits de l'homme
je ne quitterai jamais mon bel jamais
les jeunes majoritaire dans le pays sont
les premiers frappés par la crise et le
chômage
tous rêvent sans oser toujours le dire
un changement politique privé d'espoir
et de liberté
beaucoup pourrait basculer dans l'islam